- I don't know.
Go make out with every straight
boy I ever had a crush on.
Is that weird that all I would do
is just be like a slut, like be a ho?
Yeah, if I was a (unclear), I'd be a ho.
- So if I was a woman for a day,
obviously, the first thing I would do
would be play with my boobs.
- Just be like, just doing
that for a good 30 minutes.
- I'd probably just lock
myself inside all day
because it's so dangerous
outside for a woman.
- I'd probably like go
mess with dudes a lot.
- And then, I would probably end up
seeing how many things I can get for free.
- I'd probably try to
hook up with somebody
and see what it's like to
have sex with a vagina.
- Probably go the whole day
with a vibrator inside me.
Something that probably feels
that good wouldn't get old,
so why not just do it the whole day.
- Buy some cute dresses,
buy some cute shoes.
- I'd probably take advantage of
the sales sections in clothing stores.
- Probably end the
night by going to a bar,
and seeing what women have to
deal with on a daily basis.
- Everything feels like it
could be a possible threat.
- I would be curious to
see what that's like,
to just walk down a street,
and have heads turn,
and assholes scream things at me.
- It would cause so much anxiety
that if I only had to do it for a day,
I think I could just lock
myself in a room, and be like,
"Hey, I'm just gonna ride
this out watching Netflix."
If I was a woman full time
and I had to go outside
because it wasn't just going to be a day,
you really have to become okay with
how dangerous the world is for you.
Probably what size boobs would I want?
Nothing extreme.
I don't want it to be a distraction,
which is interesting that guys don't
think about that, right?
It's not like, "Oh, I don't wanna dick
"that just a distraction."
Every guy's just like, "I want
the biggest fucking dick!"